economía en francés 24 me acompaña en el
estudio daniela blandón daniela muy
buenas noches comenzamos hablando de ese
informe de la cepal que revela los
efectos de la pandemia sobre la pobreza
en américa latina hola santiago buenas
noches ya había reportes preliminares
pero el oficial con corte a 2020 muestra
que más de 20 millones de personas
cayeron en la pobreza por culpa de la
pandemia y ahora este flagelo afecta a
unos 208 millones de personas en toda la
región esto quiere decir que si antes de
la crisis el 35% de los habitantes era
considerado pobre ahora lo desde el 33
7% si hablamos de pobreza extrema
santiago aquellos cuyos ingresos son
insuficientes para ellos para satisfacer
necesidades básicas está subió a su
nivel más alto en 20 años es decir 78
millones de personas o el 12,5 por
ciento de la población la tasa de
desempleo subió a dos dígitos desde el
8,1 hasta el 10 7% y se cree que apenas
2 de cada 10 puede trabajar a distancia
en esta zepa
hablemos ahora de brasil que está muy
cerca de restituir los alevinos
económicos que empezó a otorgar a lo
largo de la pandemia claro el marzo del
año pasado el gobierno lanzó un programa
federal de subsidios destinado a 68
millones de personas de escasos recursos
pero tras su expiración en diciembre
ahora el congreso busca extenderlo a
través de una enmienda constitucional
que ya pasó en el senado y ahora pasa a
la cámara de diputados el plan ha tenido
dos partes santiago los primeros siete
meses los beneficiarios recibieron 600
reales mensuales que son aproximadamente
110 dólares los últimos meses del año el
beneficio bajó a la mitad unos 55
dólares y ahora como vemos la propuesta
es de repartir unos 8 mil millones de
dólares no se sabe exactamente cómo pero
el ministerio de economía ya ha
adelantado que podría hacer de unos 45
dólares el presidente ya hay bolsonaro
ya ha advertido varias veces que los
subsidios no son eternos que no se
ilusione vamos ahora la unión europea si
buscan eliminar la brecha
de género laboral durante varios años en
este bloque de países los hombres han
ganado un 14 por ciento más que las
mujeres por hacer el mismo trabajo
santiago y sus pensiones son un 30% más
altas también por eso la comisión
europea quiere que la publicación de las
escalas salariales en las empresas no
sea voluntaria sino obligatoria
nuestra propuesta apunta a los
desequilibrios que se originan en que
los trabajadores saben muy poco y no
hacen valer sus derechos en ella los
trabajadores tendrán derecho a obtener
información los empleadores tendrán que
hacer transparente la remuneración y no
se les permitirá solicitar información
sobre salarios previos
pues la iniciativa tiene un punto más
llamativo santiago y es que las empresas
con más de 250 empleados deberán tener
información pública sobre la brecha
salarial y si las mujeres siguen en
desventaja se propone que reciban un
pago retroactivo el proyecto pasa ahora
al parlamento europeo y a cada uno de
los 27 países también la pasamos a
hablar de los productores de whisky
escocés que están de fiesta y no nos
invitaron y no nos invitaron santiago
pues mire están distanciados de bruselas
pero washington se acerca a londres cada
vez más decidieron conjuntamente
terminar de eliminar temporalmente los
aranceles que se han interpuesto de
parte y parte en medio de la eterna
disputa sobre subsidios aeronáuticos
como reino unido ya no está la unión
europea decidió negociar directamente
con eeuu desde enero ya no está cobrando
impuestos de entrada a cientos de
productos y la casa blanca acaba de
responder este jueves de igual manera
entre los productos británicos
beneficiados esta vez están santiago el
whisky escocés
las galletas o el queso stilton que ya
no tendrán esa incómoda tarifa del 25
por ciento
por los próximos cuatro meses así que a
celebrar a celebrar en estados unidos
los indicadores daniela la bolsa de
nueva york que él cerró en rojo después
de que la reserva federal hablara de un
posible repunte de la inflación en
europa los más recientes datos confirman
cierta estabilidad en la cifra de
desempleo y eso hizo que las bolsas se
cerraron dispares y en américa latina
brasil repuntó gracias a petrobras
hablemos ahora de la cifra del día para
el cierre 4000 en libras por dólar ese
es el precio récord en que se cotiza la
moneda de local de siria que experimenta
el mismo problema de su vecino líbano
esta distorsión de la tasa hizo que el
gobierno duplicará el precio del diesel
y de la gasolina también a muchas
gracias por esta actualización chips
muchas gracias a ustedes por la sintonía
siga con la programación de france 24
buenas noches
[Música]